Guten Abend, mein Name ist Ustolar, ich bin Arsinafizer Station. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschwürfe führen. Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja, guten Abend. Ich verstehe nicht gut, ich höre nicht gut.
Können Sie Ihren Namen nochmal wiederholen bitte?
Ja, mein Name ist Betül Uslu Ogullari.
Ah, okay.
Ja, das habe ich verstanden. Ein Hörgerät ist manchmal nicht so gut.
Wo kommen Sie her, Frau Doktor? Das ist kein deutscher Name, oder?
Ja, Sie haben recht. Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Sehr gut. Türkei war ich auch mal im Urlaub. Ja, sehr schönes Land.
Ja, danke.
Ich würde erst Ihre Personische Daten aufnehmen, dann komme ich gleich zu Ihrer Aktuellen Beschwerden. Ist das okay?
Okay, Frau Doktor. Manchmal muss ich nochmal fragen, weil ich höre nicht gut. Wissen Sie, deswegen?
Ja, ich verstehe. Sie können nachfragen, kein Problem.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Namen sagen?
Mein Name ist Joachim Bublad.
Können Sie bitte vor und nach Namen langsam übernehmen?
Oh, das habe ich lange nicht mehr gemacht. Ich versuche es, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es klappt.
Joachim schreibt sich mit j.
O, A, C, H, I, M.
Und mein Nachname ist Bublad. Schreibt sich B, U, B, L, A, T, H.
Bublad.
C, H, Bublad.
Ja, richtig.
Okay. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin jetzt 82 Jahre alt.
82 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
5. August 1940.
140. Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Bublad?
Ich habe mich jetzt lange nicht mehr gemessen, Frau Doktor. Ich war mal ungefähr 1,82, aber das war früher.
Jetzt bin ich bestimmt viel kleiner geworden.
2,82. Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,82 m.
Herr Bublad, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was für Beschwerde haben Sie?
Frau Doktor, mir geht es seit 2 Tagen nicht gut.
Ich habe Übelkeit, ich muss erbrechen.
Ich habe Rückenschmerzen.
Heute Morgen oder heute Nacht habe ich auch Fieber gehabt.
Heute Morgen hatte ich auch Schüttelfrost.
Es geht mir gar nicht gut.
Ich bin sehr schwach geworden.
Ich habe auch wenig getrunken in den letzten Tagen,
aber ich bin sehr schwach geworden.
Ich schaffe es gerade auf den Weg zur Toilette, das streckt mich sehr an.
Okay.
Sie haben Rückenschmerzen.
Sind diese Schmerzen rechtsseitig oder linksseitig oder in der Mitte?
Manchmal rechts, manchmal links, wechselt es.
Aber auf beiden Seiten.
Vielleicht links ein bisschen mehr als rechts, aber ich weiß nicht genau.
Okay, ich weiß nicht genau.
Und Strahlen, diese Schmerzen, ihr gehen vor hinaus?
Ja, die gehen so nach unten.
Und dann, ob es sich nach vorne in den Bauch rein.
Aber nie die Leisten rein, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr.
Leisten.
Beidem Leisten?
Ja, links ein bisschen mehr als rechts.
Ja, Herr Büleck, Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie Fieber haben.
Haben Sie es gemessen?
Ja, wir haben auch gemessen, ungefähr 39,5 war das gewesen.
Wann war das gestern oder heute?
Heute, heute Morgen.
Okay.
Dagegen haben Sie etwas eingenommen?
Ich habe jetzt nochmal zwei Tabletten Paracetamol genommen,
das ist nämlich oft auch ein wegen anderen Beschwerden, die ich habe.
Aber hat Morissi etwas gebracht, also es geht mir immer noch nicht gut.
Okay, wie sind Sie?
Das waren normalen Tabletten, ich glaube, es sind 500 Millikamm Tabletten,
davon habe ich zwei genommen.
Okay.
Ja, Sie haben Erbriation.
Wann haben Sie Leisten mal Erbrocken?
Heute Morgen.
Ja, mehrfach auch, zwei Mal.
Gestern habe ich auch Erbriken.
Wieso das Erbriken aus?
War aufs heißt ein bisschen gallig mit dabei, aber sonst war das nur gelbe Physik.
Okay.
Sie haben ständig Übelkeit.
Ja, seit drei Tagen für habe ich Übelkeit, ja.
Okay.
Sie haben auch Probleme bei Basalas.
Hab uns nicht schmerzt, bei Basalas.
Ja, ich trink halt nicht mehr viel, deswegen brennt das schon, weil es sehr konzentriert der Urin, glaube ich.
Und ich muss oft raus, also normalerweise nicht so oft, aber jetzt, in den letzten Tagen,
muss ich so dauernd auf die Toilette gehen.
Okay.
Sechs Sieben.
Hab Sie Blut in Urin gesehen?
Also es war eher ein bisschen konzentrierter, aber ich glaube es war kein Blut.
Ich bin aber nicht sicher.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ich habe bis zu den letzten Tagen auch nicht viel gegessen, nicht getrunken,
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch keinen Stuhlgang für zwei Tage mehr.
Ich weiß, dass ich jeden Tag Stuhlgang frehe.
Okay.
Sie hatten lastes Stuhlgang vor zwei Tagen.
Ja, richtig.
Sie haben Rückenchimmersen.
Wie bewerten Sie es, wobei auf einer Schmerzstekala, wobei ein Zerlacht aber Senzerstab ist?
Ja, das ist schon sehr stark.
Ich würde so acht sagen, acht bis neun vielleicht.
Okay.
Ja, wie beschreiben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Sind sie eher stetschend?
Er ist sehr dumpf.
Sind Sie immer da oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Gehen auch wieder weg und dann kommen Sie wieder.
Es ist unterschiedlich, so dumpf und pochend, klopfend.
Okay.
Warum Sie solche Beschwerden schon einmal erleben?
Solche nicht.
Ich habe immer Rückenchmerzen gehabt, weil ich meine, wir werden so alles kaputt.
Deswegen habe ich auch viele Medikamente gehabt.
Aber diese Schmerzen sind anders, diesmal, finde ich.
Ich verstehe, dass Sie deswegen schon nicht bei einem Arzt gewesen sind.
Ja, das ist neu.
3-4 Tage vielleicht.
Ja, Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie eine Discos prolapsus haben.
Was ist das nochmal, was Sie sagen?
Sie haben Bandschargen für File.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie eine Problem mit Rücken haben.
Das könnte Bandschargen für File sein oder?
Vorvoll hat mir keiner gesagt, aber es wäre alles ziemlich abgenutzt bei mir, die wir wollen.
Vielleicht ist auch die Bandschargen abgenutzt, ich weiß nicht genau.
Wir sind nicht.
Kann sein.
Leidung Sie an Irgan Barshan für Erkrankungen?
Ja, da habe ich einige Produkte.
Ich habe Zugekrankheit, auch schon seit 15 Jahren, glaube ich.
Und Spritze auch Insulin.
Ich habe Gicht, aber ich habe schon lange keinen Gichtanfall gehabt.
Wann war das das letzte Anfall?
Vor 10 Jahren vielleicht.
Nehmen Sie dagegen keine Medikamente?
Ja, der Arzt hat mir Medikamente aufgeschrieben,
das Alu-Purinol, nehme ich an.
Dann habe ich einen, bitte.
Ich habe einen Herzschrittmacher bekommen, auch schon vor ungefähr 10 Jahren gewesen.
Und mannenierenwerte waren nicht gut, hat der Doktor gesagt,
ich habe so eine chronische Nierenproblem.
Vielleicht auch Zucker, das konnte ich nicht genau sagen.
Dann nehme ich Medikamente an wegen der Prostata auch noch.
Und Schmerzmedikaparizisten.
Prostata fargrosserik?
Ja, das hat er dann gesagt, ich muss immer nachts raus,
zwei, drei Mal.
Jetzt häufiger, aber das habe ich schon lange.
Okay, ich fange da.
Ja, Zineinem Regalmest Alu-Purinol,
ein bisschen Dosierung.
Eine 100 Milligramm Tablette war das abends.
Abends.
Okay, und was nehmen Sie noch ein?
Also ich habe dann diese Prostata Tablette, duodat.
Duodat.
Eine kappsende Tablette.
Was sind Sie, Dosierung?
Weiß ich nicht, Herr Doktor, habe ich es nicht hier zum Kopf.
Nur einmal?
Eine pro Tag, ja.
Dann habe ich wegen der Blutverdünnung,
wegen Herzschrittmacher auch bekommen gehabt,
Xarelto, 15 Milligramm, jeden Tag nämlich eine ein.
Dann habe ich noch wegen der Schilddröse L-Tiroxin.
Schilddrösen-Unterfunktion?
Ja, ich hatte unter Funktionen, deswegen hat er mir Medikamente gegeben.
Okay.
Und dann habe ich, weil meine Stimmung manchmal nicht gut war,
hat der Doktor mir ein Medikament aufgeschrieben.
Er heißt Sertralin.
Er hat abends 23, 25 Milligramm.
Seit wann nehmen Sie Sertralin?
So seit zwei, drei Jahren habe ich das.
Nachdem meine Frau gestorben ist, habe ich das dann bekommen vom Arzt.
Okay.
Ertroxin, seit wann nehmen Sie das?
Oh, das ist schon lange, auch bestimmt schon über zehn Jahre.
Über zehn Jahre.
Okay.
Herr Boglert, haben Sie Allergie?
Ich glaube, ich habe mal gegen Penicillin allergisch reagiert.
Deswegen hat der Doktor das nicht mehr verschrieben.
Ich habe nicht so am ganzen Körper einen Aufschlag gehabt.
Er hat gesagt, das ist eine Penicillin Allergie.
Okay.
Herr Boglert, rauchen Sie?
Ich habe aufgehört.
Ich habe lange geraucht früher, aber ich habe mit ungefähr vor zehn,
zwölf Jahren aufgehört zu rauchen.
Oh, zehn Jahre.
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Vorher habe ich mit Unterbrechungen,
ich würde sagen vielleicht 30, 40 Jahre bestimmt.
30 Jahre.
Wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie geraucht?
Das waren mal zehn, mal 20 unterschiedlich.
Also nie mehr als eine Schachtel pro Tag.
Okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol, regelnmäßig oder gelegenkisch?
Also das letzte Mal kann ich nicht mehr erinnern.
Nur das ist schon lange her.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht per se nicht.
Das ist eine reine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie erfahrt mit den Drogen?
Mit was bitte, Frau Doktor?
Drogen.
Ist man te so?
Ach, Drogen.
Die Heroin oder sowas.
Nein, ich habe keinen Drogen genommen.
Keine.
Ja.
Sie haben einige Krönchen für Erkrankungen.
Ich würde gerne auch Ihre Impfstattes wissen.
Würden Sie gegen Corona geimpft oder?
Ja, ich bin es fünfmal gegen Corona geimpft schon.
Ich habe es fünfmal.
Hatten Sie weitere Impfungen wie Pneumokok oder Influenza?
Also Grippe ist auch, mache ich jedes Jahr.
Andere weiß ich nicht, ich muss sagen.
Grippe und Corona habe ich auf jeden Fall.
Okay.
Und auch gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Nein, ich habe lange nicht.
Okay.
Und waren Sie in letzten 6 Monaten im Ausland?
Nein, schon lange nicht.
Okay.
Ja, habe ich jetzt über Ihre Familiengeschichte etwas fragen.
Leben, Ihre Eltern, ja, ich meinte, ich hatte irgendetwas für Erkrankungen.
Sie sind schon lange tot, ich überlege gerade, warum die gestorben sind.
Also ich weiß nicht, meine Mutter hatte auch Zucker, aber andere Krankheiten,
ich erinnere mich nicht mehr, mein Vater hatte Herzprobleme,
genau weil ich dort schon lange her.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe zwei Geschwister, ja.
Okay.
Beide sind gesund?
Und die haben auch Krankheiten.
Also der eine hat multipsisklerose.
Und der andere hat Herzprobleme mit Herzinfarkt gehabt und hat auch Stens so ausgekommen.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Bucklitz, was haben Sie beruflich gemacht?
Ich habe Autos verkauft, beim Autohandler habe ich gearbeitet.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin Vervetler, also meine Frau ist gestorben leider.
Leben Sie alleine?
Ich liebe alleine.
Okay.
Können Sie alltagliche Aufgabe selbst erledigen?
Bisher habe ich das alles gemacht, aber jetzt, wo ich krank bin,
schaffe ich das nicht mehr, Frau Doktor.
Deswegen würde ich auch gerne im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ja.
Ich verstehe.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, Sie haben wichtige Probleme.
Deswegen werden wir sich stationär aufnehmen.
Okay.
Sie haben eventuell eine Nierenprobleme.
Ja.
Dann werden wir Ihnen eine medikamenteuse Therapie einladen.
Okay, gut.
Ja, das ist sehr nett von Ihnen, dass ich im Krankenhaus bleiben darf.
Danke.
Wir würden Ihnen gerne helfen.
Okay.
Brauen Sie noch von mir Unterlagen?
Oder kann ich noch etwas Ihnen geben?
Ja.
Ich möchte auch Ihre Akten wieder kontrollieren.
Okay.
Ja.
Und dann gleich das andere Mal.
Ja, alles klar.
Frau Doktor, ich bin auch privat versichert.
Kann ich Einzelzimmer bekommen bei Ihnen?
Ja, natürlich.
Wir haben eine Einzelzimmer, aber ich muss erst kontrollieren.
Okay, danke.
Ja, weil ich muss sehr oft auf Toilette gehen.
Wenn ich mit jemandem zusammenliege, ist das immer,
störe ich andere Leute, das möchte ich nicht.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge.
Ja, das ist kein Problem.
Okay, gut.
Und den Krankensprächsland können Sie sagen, dass ich schwerhörig bin,
dass Sie manchmal dann lauter reden müssen mit mir.
Ja, ich werde Bescheid geben.
Sie können Ihnen dabei helfen, laut sprechen.
Das ist kein Problem.
Ich muss ein Katheter bekommen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Sie haben ja schon ein Problem.
Sie haben eine Überraschung.
Sie müssen auch auf die Medikamente gehen.
Okay, ich meine, Urin-Katheter.
Nein, Urin-Katheter.
Urin-Katheter.
Er ist ein Muslim, der auch Diagnostische Masnamen hat.
Ja, vielleicht wird das für mich,
damit ich nicht so oft auf Toilette gehen muss.
Ich verstehe Ihre Sorge, aber wenn ich Ihnen eine Therapie gebe,
dann werde ich diese Probleme, wenn ich sie geben will.
Okay, verstehe.
Gut, gut, alles klar.
Danke Frau Dr.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Wie schön.
Guten Abend, Herr Burglat.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
70 Kilogramm.
Haben Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten
Gehwichsen derok, Gehwichsabnahme oder Abnahme?
Ungefähr gleich.
Danke schön.
Frau Dr., Sie haben gefragt, zwei Mal nach Größe.
Und er hört auch schlecht.
Ich habe ja einen Ansatz bekommen,
weswegen habe ich...
Aber er hört auch schlecht, deswegen ist es kein Problem.
Was hätten Sie noch gefragt?
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Haben Sie schon gesagt?
Ich habe schon angefangen.
Ich wollte noch Fragen sammeln.
An amästische Fragen oder Kommentare.
Hat alles gefragt worden?
Haben Sie gefragt, ob ich dicke Beine habe?
Nein.
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Haben Sie gefragt, wie mein Urin aussieht?
Haben Sie Blut dabei?
Ja, ich habe gefragt.
Sehr konzentriert.
Haben Sie gefragt, wie mein Urin riecht?
Nein.
Riecht unangenehm.
Übel riechen.
Was gibt es noch für Fragen?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Es wäre auch wichtig,
ob der Patient in den letzten Tagen
Genugwasser trinken konnte.
Nein.
Er hat gesagt, er hat wenig getrunken.
Er hat wenig getrunken,
weil er nicht auf Tröte gehen wollte.
Weil er schwach ist, ist ein Teufelskreis.
Trinkt weniger, ist dann noch mehr in den Funktionsstörungen.
Was gibt es noch für Fragen?
Medikament haben wir gefragt.
Welche Risikofaktoren für Handwerksinfektionen?
Prostatik barplosi.
Er hat chronische Erkrankungen.
Diabetes, Melizos,
Geist, Anfall,
Erletzungen.
Er hat eine andere Erkrankung.
Er hat einen anderen Anfall.
Wenn eine Frau mit Handwerksinfektionen kommt,
fragen sie nach anderen Beschwerden.
Bei einem 28-jährigen Mann ist das keine Frage.
Bei einer jungen Person,
ist das ein Problem.
Die haben das nicht zu tun.
Wie nennt man diese Probleme,
wenn Frauen Handwerksinfektionen bekommen?
Kennen sie auch,
wenn man das nennt?
Diabetes,
Melizos,
bei Frauen dann auch nutzt. Also bezogen auf die sexual Aktivität.
Hannimons ist das. Aber beim alten Mann der hat kein Hannimon mehr, glaube ich.
Okay, gut, dann wenn keine weiteren Kommentare fragen sind, können wir zu
erst Gespräche gehen, oder? Ja. Ja, Herr Oberjahrs, ich habe heute einen neuen Patient
nachgenommen, wenn Sie seit, hätten würde ich Ihnen vorstellen. Ja, gerne, bitte schön.
Ja, es handelt sich um, ich habe ein Buglet, ja, ich habe ein Buglet.
Er ist, er ist, er ist 80 Jahre alt, 70 Kilogramm schwer, 1 Meter alt, 80, groß.
Er kam heute wegen Zeit, der Tag, 5.Händer, Dumfer, Rücken Schmerz,
For Weagum, Link Sartek, So uns, So uns und diese Schmerz sind wirb,
in den Leisten, in den Yunalberaş, aus Stralen.
Er klackte auf über, fiba, Schuttgarflos, nausea und emesis.
Er hat 2 Mal Ergobl, das Ergobl eine Zahngarlik aus,
der gegen, da gegen hat er peristomal 2 Mal 5,5 Milligramm
und, Anfall Erkrankung, zahen die Folgen der Bekannt,
im Folgen der Bekannt, ja, Diabetes mei litus,
5.Jahren, 5.Jahren,
gest, ja, für Leiste, Leiste, gest, der Leiste, gest, Anfall, ist für 10
Jahrlinge gewesen und sein Haus, laut seinem Hausfarts, hat er
Ergobl den Nieren, das kann eine Chronische Nieren
Erkrankung sein, ja, und er leidet auf,
bei mir, Prostatachipartiles, Hypothriose und Depression, ja,
und Erklackt und Chronische Ruckeinche Marksen.
An Medikation, Nime, Nint, Er, Insulin, Schpritze, Alloprynal,
800 Milligramm, no 1 Mal, Saraito, 10 Milligramm,
Doadat, Kapsel, no 1 Mal, und El Troxin,
seit, seit über 10 Jahren, und Sertrelin, seit 2,
bis 3 Jahre, ja, ich habe über Operation Nicht-Frag, ich werde diese Frage
beider für euch, um zu sprechen,
ja, er hat auch Penicillin-Allergie,
dies ist durch Exantem-Oys, er,
er hat eine Herzkrankheit,
eine Herzimpfung,
und er hat eine Herzimpfung,
er hat beim Behandeln,
er hat Aufeuvertreffend gearbeitet, er ist fertig,
und er lebt so lange,
Ja, aufgrund der anamnistischen Angaben gehe ich von einer akuten Pülennephritis aus,
als differenzial Diagnose käme, die Artikulitis nephrolitiasis, jas und sistitis in Betracht.
Ich habe eine Art von Blutbild, Blutzenkung, Äschelung, Dekar, CRP, Urinuntersuchung, Urinkultur, Nieren, Retentionparameter,
Duschwürre, Urinkultur, Blutkulturen, Blutkulturen, wenn eine anhaltende Feber vorliegt, dann würde ich eine Blutkulturen abnehmen.
Sie gehen von einer akuten Pülennephritis aus, was erwarten Sie für Keim oder der häufigste Keim?
Ja, es gibt einige häufige Regen.
Erst ist es Schiakoli und Klebstierna und Prätosumrabis.
Jetzt haben Sie gesagt, die Macht nach Ultraschall ist wichtig, ja, unbedingt.
Können Sie mir noch mal sagen, welchen Beschwerden der Patienten hat beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, er hat diese...
Was heißt das? Was ist die Story?
Das ist der schwierigste Wasserlassen.
Er musste viel auf der Toilette geben.
Polakisturi.
Er hat dunkler Urin.
Ich finde, dunkler Urin.
Hat er auch Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen?
Ja.
Er hat Schmerzen.
Polakisturi.
Ja, auch.
Alkuri.
Ja, das ist ein Schmerzen-Wasserlassen.
Gut.
Ja, wie würden Sie jetzt Ihnen behandeln mit Patienten?
Der stationäre Ambulant?
Ja, agentlich, natürlich, für die Stationäreufnahme.
Der Patient möchte die Stationäreufnahme erlebt.
Aber der erste Urin hat eine wichtige Beschwerde.
Ich meine, Schwergerät ist hoch wie Fiba, Noazia,
und ja, Emesis, Schwerfos, ja.
Er ist auch ein altes Patient.
Er hat viele chronische Erkrankungen.
Gut, Sie würden ihm Antibiotika geben, nehme ich mal an, ja?
Ja.
Er hat eine Zugangklinik, eine Zugangklinik und Flüssigkeit zu führen.
Dann Antibiotika würde ich beginnen.
Und als Antibiotika würde ich Flourationalen beginnen.
Er hat auch Penicillin-Alarge, wir müssen ihn auch behalten.
Ja, richtig, sehr gut.
Worauf müssen Sie bei Flourationalen, bei älteren Patienten achten?
Ja, das kann einige Nebenwirkungen verursachen.
Vielleicht, ich erinnere mich, dass es daran aber nicht ein Problem ist.
Es ist nicht unbedingt das größte Problem bei Flourationalen,
aber was gibt es dann noch bei älteren Patienten?
Sie können neuropsychiatrische Probleme machen.
Ich meine das.
Also schwere psychiatrische Störungen auch entwickeln, ja?
Ja, ich meine das.
Was wollte ich noch fragen?
Nehmen Sie einen Urin-Katheter, den Patienten?
Ich würde Urin-Katheter nicht beforschen.
Ja, weil wir müssen erst Beschwerde, Linden und Bakterien bezahlt werden.
Ja, das stimmt.
Sie haben ja gesagt, die Ursache bei den Patienten erklärt sich durch die Begleiterkrankungen
wie Alte, ordentliche Krankheiten.
Was ist ein Hauptproblem?
Was ist aus einer Nese das Richtungsweisende, dass eine pionelle Friddis entwickelt haben könnte?
Vielleicht Exerbation von prostatil-Parplasen sein.
Das kann auch sein, aber ich würde vor allem das gesagt haben, prostatil-Plasen.
Das kann bestimmt. Was passiert bei einer prostatil-Plasie?
Die prostatil-Plasie passiert eine Verengung der Brüder.
Richtig. Und was ist dann die Konflikenz?
Das Schtau kommt dann eine Handschtau.
Das kommt zu einer Handschtau.
Genau, aber die haben dann Resthahn und das ist dann nicht auch immer begünstigend für die Handwechselinslekktion.
Deswegen müssen Sie gucken, Sie haben ja gesagt, Sie machen Ultraschall.
Wenn man da jetzt eine Handtransportstörung sieht, also eine Ekthasie des Nierenbecken-Kälchestimes,
dann würde ich in der Tat einen Katheter legen.
Ja, double shape-catheter.
Nein, erst mal die ural-catheter, dass es dann wie Blatt entwert wird, damit er nicht staut.
Ja, die erste Maßnahme. Auch wenn er eine Bakterie der Pylonephritis haben sollte,
dann ist es sogar eine ursichtliche Therapie dafür.
Was ist die Komplikation bei so einer Pylonephritis?
Ja, die Örosepsis kann sich entzlichen.
Und auch chronizieren, dann keine Behandlung.
Sehr gut, bin ich sehr zufrieden mit der Vorstellung.
Jetzt kommt da noch eine Kommentare aus dem Chat.
Ich guck grad mal nach.
Was haben wir hier? Algorith, Stimmungveränderung, Kreatin, Kontraniziert, DM,
das heißt Diabetes meditus.
Das war für die Blasenkatheter, glaube ich.
Kontraniziert ist nicht ganz korrekt.
Also muss man das machen, wenn das gemeint war.
Ja, gut.
Sonstige Vorschläge, Verbesserungsvorschläge.
Was ist Ihre Spezifikation, Ihre Spezialisierung?
Meine Fraunsten.
Kein Wunder, dann macht klar, dass Sie alles wissen.